alors
or à tous il ya deux ans je travaillais
à new york en salle des marchés dans
l'une des plus grosses banques
d'investissement européennes
et c'est vrai que c'était un petit peu
la réalisation d'un rêve d'étudiant
parce que la vie à manhattan un boulot à
wall street
et puis finalement j'ai décidé tout
arrêter pour lancer une chaîne de
vulgarisation qui parle d'économie et de
finance et la première chose dont
j'aimerais vous parler que j'aimerais
vous transmettre ces où j'aimerais vous
faire passer plutôt c'est en fait
abandonner sa carrière en finance pour
faire de la vulgarisation c'est pas une
idée si débile que ça alors quand on
commence en salle des marchés la
première chose qu'on doit faire c'est
apprendre le produit financier qui nous
a été attribuée en fait il faut savoir
que les salles de marché sont organisés
autour de ce qu'on appelle des desk de
trading sur lesquels travaillent des
vendeurs des traders des années et
financier ils sont tous spécialistes
d'un seul produit financier et donc
c'est un métier qui est très technique
très complexe et moi y'a un truc que
j'adorais c'est justement à prendre le
plus de chauffage de choses possible et
ensuite me retrouver avec mes amis
autour d'une bière essayer de leur
expliquer que bah oui quand vous achetez
une option avec une courte maturité et
que vous avez une augmentation de la
volatilité sur le stock sous jacents et
ben vous pouvez tirer profit des
variations de delta ça s'appelle faire
son gamin je vous demande pas de
comprendre ce que je viens de vous
raconter là simplement
c'est pour vous dire à quel point oui
c'est complexe oui c'est passionnant
mais mes amis en général ce qui me
répondait c'est d'accord c'est bien joli
ton histoire mais nous ce qu'on aimerait
savoir c'est plutôt cité traders ils
sont si forts que ça pourquoi on a une
crise des subprimes en 2008 ou encore
toi qui travaillent en salle des marchés
tu dois tout connaître de l'économie
qu'est ce que tu ferais pour sortir la
france de la crise évidemment j'avais
pas de réponse à apporter à ça pourquoi
parce que si ça c'est le monde de la
finance
moi je maîtrisais uniquement cette
partie là point rouge une grande
différence entre maîtriser un produit
financier et comprend tous les autres
produits financiers la manière dont ils
interagissent de la manière qu une fois
que vous avez compris le monde de la
finance
vous n'avez pas compris l'économie
l'économie c'est encore différent et
même si vous comprenez la finance et
l'économie
vous comprenez pas comment fonctionne le
monde parce que là derrière il faut
rajouter de l'histoire de la politique
de la sociologie là
psychologie des mathématiques de la
biologie etc etc
finalement la vulgarisation ça vous
permet de prendre un peu de recul et de
comprendre comment tout ça fonctionne
l'autre échappatoire étant si vous
voulez comprendre comment fonctionne le
monde
eh bien il vous faut beaucoup de temps
et beaucoup de livres comme mon sens
c'est quand même pratique de passer par
des vulgarisateurs alors non la question
c'est ok mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on
aurait besoin de comprendre comment
fonctionne ce monde aussi complexe
à mon avis il ya au moins trois points
on peut donner le numéro un ce serait de
dire bah finalement c'est juste sympa de
comprendre comment ça marche par simple
curiosité
le deuxième point ce serait après tout
vous êtes citoyen vous avez un droit de
vote vous avez un droit de grève
vous avez le droit de militer de
boycotter vous avez un droit
d'expression
et si vous voulez utiliser ces droits
correctement il faut avoir des idées à
défendre pour avoir des idées à défendre
il faut avoir identifié les problèmes et
pour pouvoir identifier les problèmes il
faut comprendre comment ça marche
le troisième point c'est probablement
pour des raisons existentielle
peut-être que ça vous arrive pourquoi
est ce que je me lève le matin pour
aller travailler quel est mon rôle à
quoi je sers dans la société
pour répondre à ces questions là il faut
être justement incapable de prendre du
recul et de comprendre comment ça marche
d'où l'importance des vulgarisateurs
alors j'espère qu'avec tout ça je vous
ai convaincus que la vulgarisation
s'était pas n'importe quoi on en a
besoin
peut-être que certains d'entre vous
envie de lancer une chaîne youtube et se
disent bah oui c'est ce qu'il faut faire
allons-y faisons la vulgarisation
donc j'aimerais partager un petit peu
avec vous les méthodes que j'utilise moi
pour essayer de faire une bonne vidéo
voilà j'ai pas toutes les clés c'est
juste ma façon d'aborder le sujet jeudi
à l'est toujours ça comme une espèce de
check list en trois points le premier
point est temps auquel je dois maîtriser
le sujet si je dois en parler je dois
d'abord savoir de quoi je parle
deuxième point il faut que une fois que
j'explique tout ça les gens se disent ok
on a compris et on va retenir
l'information et le troisième point
c'est il faut que la vidéo soit cool
attractive pour pas que au bout de 30
secondes vous ayez envie de cliquer
ailleurs alors le premier point je
voudrais rester c'est le dernier en fait
parce que comme on parle de vidéos
médias audiovisuels on a du sens et on a
des images et bien souvent on va vouloir
s'attaquer premièrement à l'image on se
dit voilà il me faut une super caméra il
me faut des supers effets spéciaux il
faut un décor de malades et il faut je
pas des super costumes etc etc
à mon avis ce qui est au coeur d'une
vidéo d'une égalisation c'est pas
l'image c'est le texte c'est ce que vous
allez dire c'est la manière dont vous
allez le dire c'est la manière vous
allez construire un argumentaire
c'est ça qui est important l'image elle
arrive en deuxième pour essayer
d'illustrer vos propos pour les rendre
plus claire keim et il faut pas que
quelqu'un regarde vos vidéos en se
disant c'était génial mais j'ai rien
appris en fait fin je sais plus ce que
ce que j'ai vu ça c'est un vrai problème
donc ce qui est au coeur c'est le texte
alors qu'est ce qu'on met dans ce texte
la première chose ce serait d'essayer de
lister les différentes notions les
différents concepts qu'on veut expliquer
donc là c'est représenté par les lettres
de a jusqu à g et puis une information
principale qui est l'information qu'on
veut que les gens comprennent et
retiennent pour rien à voir plusieurs
ici j'en wilkinson il s'agit évidemment
pas de lister tout ça en disant ok je
vais vous expliquer à puis après je vous
explique et b puis c etc etc
ça marche pas comme ça il faut essayer
d'organiser un petit peu tout ça faut
qu'il y ait une structure
l'idée derrière c'est que si je vous
parle de à
derrière je vais vous parler forcément
2d ensuite je mets une parenthèse vous
parle de baies et de ces pluies 2e et
ensuite on peut reprendre
ok il faut que vous puissiez visualiser
cette structure pourquoi
logique si c'est pas logique vous allez
voir les choses un peu comme ça par
exemple je vous parle des appuis de bay
puis deux des balles à vous faites la
mauvaise connexion et pendant que vous
êtes en train de vous poser la question
mais attends c'est pas logique et pas
compris ben moi je suis en train de
raconter quelque chose l'écoutait pas et
vous perdez le film complètement donc la
structure de l'exploser est très très
importante
personnellement je passe énormément de
temps là-dessus si vous avez fait ça
correctement normalement vous avez
valider le deuxième point mais on n'a
toujours pas validé le premier qui est
être maître de son sujet alors déjà je
dirais que si vous êtes capable
d'organiser vos idées vous idée comme ça
ça veut dire que a priori vous maîtrisez
quand même pas mal le sujet mais pour
aller plus loin c'est toujours la classe
d'avoir un physicien célèbre dans ses
présentations
j'aimerais citer einstein qui a dit si
vous ne pouvez expliquer un concept un
enfant de 6 ans c'est que vous ne
comprenez pas complètement et j'espère
que cette citation est correct parce que
j'ai aussi lu sur internet qu'il avait
dit j'ai peur du jour où de fausses
citations de moi circuleront sur
internet alors mettons que cette
première citation soit correcte qu'est
ce qu'il a voulu dire einstein mon sens
c'est pas qu'il vous faut toujours un
enfant de 6 ans à côté de vous pour
tester vos connaissances mais plutôt
d'essayer de comprendre comment les
enfants résonne et s'il ya deux points
importants d'abord un les enfants ils
n'ont pas peur de poser des questions et
il pose des questions souvent dérangeant
parce qu'en fait eh ben on a
l'impression de connaître la réponse
apparaît évident mais on n'arrive pas à
l'expliquer et probablement si on
n'arrive pas à l'expliquer c'est qu'on
l'a pas si bien compris ce que ça alors
j'aimerais illustrer sa avec un petit
schéma hockey ici c'est quoi c'est le
cycle de l'eau en très très simplifié
vous avez un nuage
il pleut sur la montagne l'eau ruisselle
sa forme des retenues d'eau lacs
rivières océans le soleil chauffe l'eau
l'eau s'évapore hop ça redevient
condensation en haute atmosphère sarr
forme des nuages etc
il pleut ok très bien la boucle est
bouclée une question pourrait poser un
enfant c'est c'est quoi le l'évaporation
en fait c'est vrai l'évaporation sein
c'est assez facile pour nous c'est un
concept plutôt simple mais pour un
enfant c'est pas évident alors comment
pour expliquer ce un enfant bas
l'évaporation ok il ya plusieurs stades
plusieurs états de l'eau ok c'est le
solide quand il fait froid caisse etc la
neige c'est la glace quand il fait
normal ces liquides et puis quand il
fait chaud ça s'évapore ça devient gaz
c'est un gaz plus les éclaire donc il
monte puis quand il est rendu assez haut
il
fradi à nouveau il redevient de l'eau et
à pipe le ok très bien donc pourrais
vous dire cet enfant imaginaire
ça veut dire que ça s'évapore que quand
il fait chaud
bah oui ça s'évapore que quand il fait
chaud mais du coup ça veut dire que ça
s'évapore que l'été au soleil n'ont
évidemment pas ça s'évapore aussi
l'hiver et dans la nuit du coup il ya
forcément un truc qui manque dans votre
démonstration et c'est la notion de
pression les étables au change en
fonction de la température et de la
pression mais du coup ça veut dire que
vous pouvez pas expliquer l'évaporation
correctement si vous n'êtes pas compris
ce que c'est que la pression et comment
ça marche et donc vous voyez que en
déconstruisant les concepts comme ça en
revenant à la source
vous êtes capable de voir si vous
maîtrisez ou si vous maîtrisez pas le
sujet ici ça veut dire que si je
reprends mon exemple de larmes de votre
raisonnement vous avez construit comme
ça en réalité dans votre tête ça devrait
plutôt ressembler à ça vous êtes capable
de tout déconstruire et il ya toujours
un sens derrière c'est toujours logique
ça fonctionne toujours très bien ça veut
pas dire que c'est ça que vous allez
présenter dans la vidéo c'est à dire que
au moins vous êtes capable de
déconstruire à un ou deux niveaux en
dessous de ce que vous allez expliquer
ok maintenant avec ça normalement on
avait l'idée du coup le premier point
est mort plus qu'un point à bédié
comment on fait pour avoir une vidéo qui
soit intéressante attractif fun que les
gens cliquent pas ailleurs au bout de
deux minutes
ici encore une fois j'ai pas la réponse
mais pour moi ce qui est au centre de la
vidéo c'est toujours le texte si le
texte est bien écrit et bien dis bien
joué ça devrait être suffisant pour que
les gens restent jusqu'au bout de la
vidéo et là j'ai deux références qui
sont platon et isaac asimov
alors vous connaissez probablement le
premier platon isaac asimov pour ceux
qui connaissent pas c'est un auteur de
science fiction
quel est le rapport entre ces deux
auteurs pour moi c'est ils ont écrit des
dialogues vraiment super chouette platon
il plutôt que d'écrire un texte d'un
seul tenant
pour exposer ses idées il mettait en
scène un héros une espère voir une
espèce de héros qui devait affronter des
personnages qui avait pas les mêmes
opinions que lui et lui il devait donc
défendre ses idées alors certains
arguments qu'il avait à défendre a été
relativement simple mais parfois il y
avait des personnages qui étaient
particulièrement perspicace et qui
proposait des idées vraiment on a envie
envie d'y croire et on se demandait
comment est ce que le héros allait
réussir à retourner la situation et donc
ça nous pousse à aller jusqu'au bout du
texte et à essayer de comprendre ce qui
se passe
pour isaac asimov c'est un peu le même
principe lui il aimait bien mettre en
scène des personnages extrêmement
intelligent et charismatique avec des
idées opposées qui vont s'affronter dans
un espèce de joutes oratoires
ce qui est particulièrement intéressant
à faire avec ça c'est que quand le
premier personnage arrive et expose ses
idées
c'est logique c'est clair on est tout à
fait d'accord avec lui et quand le
deuxième personnage arrive pour donner
la réponse eh ben c'est logique c'est
clair et on change d'avis et ça peut
durer comme ça pendant dix pages et ça
nous emmène forcément jusqu'au bout moi
j'essaye de me servir de cette idée là
donc dans mes vidéos j'ai deux
personnages un professeur et un élève je
passe énormément de temps sur l'écriture
des 10 de ce que va dire le professeur
ce que je veux que ce soit clair mais
d'un autre côté je passe aussi
énormément de temps sur les questions
que va poser l'élève
l'idée c'est pouvoir sauter d'une notion
à l'autre mais aussi parfois de mettre
en danger mon personnage du professeur
pour que le public se disent ok mais là
comment il va réussir à retourner le
truc donc ça c'est la première et de la
deuxième chose c'est j'essaye de faire
en sorte que les gens s'identifient au
personnage alors et si possible bascule
de l'un l'autre
alors là l'idée pour moi c'est plutôt de
commencer très simple et avec des
concepts qui sont très simples donc le
public s'identifie plus tôt au
personnage du professeur au début on
écoute les questions mais enfin on a la
réponse et la vidéo agi un petit peu
plus comme un quiz
on veut vérifier ses connaissances donc
on attend la réponse du professeur et
puis au fur et à mesure que ça devient
compliqué eh ben on se rend compte que
finalement les questions que posent les
élèves sont quand même assez pertinente
et en fait c'est exactement la question
qu'on se pose est petit à petit comme ça
on transfère vers le personnage de
l'étudiant et ça normalement ça devrait
pousser le public à aller jusqu'au bout
de la vidéo parce qu'ils veulent avoir
le fin mot de l'histoire
bon avec cette méthode là normalement on
a validé les trois points qui vous
devriez enfin je pense que on a au final
une bonne vidéo de vulgarisation alors
ce que j'aimerais que vous reteniez de
ce que je viens de vous raconter là
c'est peut-être deux choses la première
c'est oui on a besoin de vulgarisateur
on a besoin de la vulgarisation c'est
important ça permet de prendre du recul
sur les choses ça prendra de comprendre
comment fonctionne le monde et pourquoi
on aurait besoin de ça parce qu'à la
fois on est curieux parce que si on veut
être des citoyens éduqués et aussi
peut-être pour avoir quelques réponses à
certaines questions existentielles qu'on
se pose et puis le deuxième point c'est
ok c'est intéressant de d'écouté des
vulgarisateurs de s'intéresser mais
c'est aussi
important de vulgariser soi même
pourquoi parce que en vulgarisant on est
capable de déconstruire ses idées pour
essayer de les exposer aux autres et en
faisant ça on se rend compte que parfois
et ben on avait la même mauvaise opinion
sur certaines choses moi ça m'est arrivé
des tas de fois de préparer une vidéo
d'avoir des idées et de venir mais en
fait il faut complètement que je remette
en question ma façon de penser là ça va
pas du tout c'est un moyen d'auto
critique très efficace donc encore une
fois intéressez-vous aux bulgares isat
heures la vulgarisation c'est cool mais
si possible essayez vous même aussi de
vulgariser certains sûr merci
[Applaudissements]